et devinez quoi je ne vais pas vous
parler de thomas pesquet ce même nom
mais une journée 100% sans thomas
pesquet de ses remplaçants aux
américains et un allemand qui sont en
vol vers l'iss elle est venue d'une
bonne blague c'est donc un décollage
réussi pour la nasa et space x à bord de
la capsule trois américains allemands
qui vendent prendre la relève du
français de ses coéquipiers au sein de
l' iss pour une mission au total qui
durera six mois rémy ouvre à rester
debout sur sa montgolfière à 4016 m
dette d'altitude il a assuré qu'il
voulait se rapprocher de là où était
thomas pesquet de la station sur
quatre cents kilomètres au-dessus de la
terre brûlée par un peu un peu de chemin
le vol a été réalisé hier par le père et
le fils ouvrard connu dans le monde de
la montgolfière le duo a survolé les
plaines de la vienne pour promouvoir le
numéro du téléthon
mais beaucoup chanté ensemble avec
sandrine mais oui énormément normalement
nous avons chanté au gala de la
fondation alzheimer plusieurs fois on a
des souvenirs mais oui parce que nico
aussi quatre roulettes un petit moteur
voilà peut-être comment sera équipé le
piéton de l'an 2000 c'est un peu
encombrant c'est simple et c'est
économique que de livres aux 1000 km et
voilà le problème de la circulation
résolu c'est également un bon moyen pour
ne pas user ses chaussures années 2050
on ne sort plus jamais sans ses lunettes
de protection
et ses bottes spécial
émanations de gaz poussières notre
planète étouffe sous les déchets
mais l'équipe de cash est toujours là
elle n'a pas pris une ride tokyo la plus
grande mégapole de la planète 37
millions d'habitants et des rues sans
poubelle à la propreté légendaire
bonsoir à tous bienvenue il est 19
heures on va partir comme d'habitude
pour une petite mission propreté si vous
êtes toujours motivé
ce soir là ils sont une trentaine des
bénévoles à les nettoyer la chaussée la
terre est devenu une décharge à ciel
ouvert
ou des bêtes prolifèrent
les sorties au grand air ressemble
désormais à ça
ça fait rêver
eh bien c'est ce qui pourrait vraiment
arrivé
selon la banque mondiale la quantité de
déchets augmentera de 70 % d'ici à 2050
si rien ne change on habite dans le
quartier comme on trouve que parfois
tout n'est pas parfaitement propre on ne
vient donner un coup de main cette
association pour nous c'est une activité
comme une autre et c'est surtout
l'occasion de faire une promenade
familiale qui permet de passer du temps
avec les enfants c'est qu'ils
allaient venir on me suivez
oui bien sûr on part dans des travers
qui sont bien différentes
scènes de nettoyage banal au pays du
soleil levant une affaire d'éducation
qui commence dès l'enfance à l'école
tradition typiquement nippone ce sont
les élèves qui nettoie eux mêmes pendant
10 minutes tous les jours leur classe du
solo table en passant par le tableau et
même les couloirs extérieurs
c'est leur salle de classe leur
environnement de travail il s'étale de
la nettoyer
vaut mieux remonter ses manches que de
baisser son froc voilà c'est une façon
de dire l'europe dans la vie faut y
aller quoi personne ne nous attend
fouilles avaient d'emblée il nous
dévoile ses petits trucs pour bien
passer à la télé
je vais vous dire jean talon non
mon portefeuille ça pour que ça sonne
pas oui c'est une manne pour avoir l'air
d'être main se plaire aux filles et
je sais que vous êtes un ancien dentiste
et je me posais cette question est ce
que maintenant vous c'est la première
chose que vous continuez à regarder chez
les gens
des formations professionnelles c'est
vrai que c'était le cas pendant tout le
monde mes études et mon père me disent
heureusement que t'as pas fait urologie
en fait les trois ans de cette
publication instagram qu'elle avait
posté le 11 novembre 2018 une pelle
photo qui transpire l'amour et cette
légende avec ma beauté je rigole parce
que je suis en train de lui faire pipi
dessus qu'ils allaient de bon dimanche
une pensée aux morts tombés pour la
france
quelle est la différence entre la guerre
de 14-18 et le célibat non non et que
pendant le célibat les femmes aussi sous
poilus
faire
avec la voix qui me reste
avec la voix qu'il me reste car
effectivement la voix du président est
toujours
vive la république
vive la france
depuis hier soir on sait qu'il y a non
pas cinq candidats à la primaire ait
l'air mais six avec monsieur macross
donc messieurs macron est en train de
permettez moi l'expression sucer la
droite la suisse est là la roue de la
droite avec une forme de déterminisme
incroyable alors
de vélo sucer la roue c'est une
expression cycliste 1 ça veut dire qu'on
profite de l'aspiration du coureur
devant soi ce canard pourrait bien voler
la vedette au lièvre et la tortue
wrinkle a couru dimanche dernier le
marathon de new york est l'une de ses
vidéos postées sur tik tok il ya deux
jours tu nul près de 7 millions de vues
plutôt à l'aise avec une belle foulée au
milieu des autres participants
malgré les encouragements le palmipède
n'a pas fini la course et s'est
volatilisé cela a suffi pour qu'un
célèbre équipementier le repère et lui
propose un contrat juteux non pas en
dollars
les en miettes de parc en apéritif c'est
quoi le programme primé chercher et
abroge ma belle rose quelques rustines
ne va pas je veux avec les branches pas
moi ça me rappelle les grands construits
sur les pulls après une broche c'est
aussi quelque chose
de sucre et donc moi j'aime beaucoup la
proche non félicia vous parlez d'une
brioche la brioche un ongle incarné et
là ils disent aussi
un coup de pouce contre later the
youtube a annoncé hier que le nombre de
10 like et comprenez je n'aime pas sous
les vidéos seraient désormais masquer
une manière selon la plateforme de
protéger des créateurs contre le
harcèlement est ce que quand on appuie
le pull rose